hello
welcome to the monitor and more
importantly welcome to 2013
if you still have the occasion to write
checks remember the three instead of the
two but that is not why we're here
nor are we here to talk about the pop
culture releases of the first week of
january because there's not really a lot
that comes out
the first week in january unless it is a
baby that was conceived in march
or april instead we're going to talk
about the monitor's 10 favorite things
from 2012
in no particular order i just wrote them
down as i thought about them and that's
how we're going to present them to you
first scott snyder's fantastic run on
batman as part of dc comics new 52 was a
conclusion of the
incredible court of owl's storyline and
the beginning of the death of the
family storyline which of course marks
the return of joker and his torn off
face held in place with power staples
good stuff looper ryan johnson's sci-fi
yarn about a hit man who has to kill
himself but does not and then they chase
each other all around the town
it is a sci-fi movie that turns into a
western with bruce willis and joseph
gordon-levitt as a younger bruce willis
and emily blunt
and jeff daniels and one of the best
child actors i have ever
seen borderlands 2 gearbox software
sequel to borderlands yeah that's right
you guessed right
it is a first-person shooter slash
role-playing game hybrid in which you
play
any one of a handful of classes and you
can level them up and there are
basically
infinite uh numbers of guns in the world
you find them you buy them you sell them
they all do different things i like to
set enemies on fire you might like to
just corrode them with acid
whatever type of havoc you like to reek
borderlands 2 lets you do it
kendrick lamar's album good kid mad city
it's his third
official album but his first major label
album this of course comes out on
interscope aftermath after he was signed
by dr dre following the incredible 2011
album
section 80. and he brings it i've talked
about this before but kendrick lamar
is possibly the most talented young
rapper working today
dark knight rises because vernon wraps
up his trilogy
in grand stermond wrong fashion
the other good side is we never have to
hear christian bale's tortured gravelly
batman voice again
still movie was awesome the whole thing
just kind of kicked
i could say that right ass ass hawkeye
matt fraction's take from marvel comics
on the
non-super-powered avengers member
doesn't sound like a lot right
but the writing is absolutely hilarious
really loved this run he started it
in august and it is going strong i
implore you to pick that up
hawkeye on marvel not part of marvel now
just
a standalone thing from the inimitable
matt fraction homeland oh my god
season two of homeland you thought that
it couldn't get crazier than season one
guess what you're wrong because it did
abu nazir nicholas brody carrie mathis
and david estes
uh saul i almost forgot manny patink's
character's name so
it is just one of the best acted most
crazy written i'm not going to say it's
the best written because some people had
some issues with the way it went in the
last three episodes or so
i didn't you got to suspend some
disbelief people if you're going to
believe that a
pow comes back and is able to
orchestrate an assassination attempt on
the
vice president then then you got to
believe anything frank ocean
channel orange the r b singer who put
out an incredible free album
last year the nostalgia ultra and
peripheral
odd future member came out with his
major label debut
and it is as power packed and soulful
and
pretter naturally self-assured as you
hoped it would be
certainly hands down one of my favorite
albums of the year and definitely worth
a listen if you haven't listened to it
yet
sons of anarchy on fx ah sam crow is
back sons of anarchy motorcycle club
redwood originals
curt sutter's crazy band of motorcycle
misfits in northern california
just was well to wall batshit this year
jimmy smith was incredible
every character kind of got to show
their strong suits even harold parano
who i don't really like turned in a good
performance as
crime lord damon pope there's a lot left
to uh
to see how it pans out next season a lot
of questions a lot of cliffhangers as
they always like to do but for me it was
the most satisfying season of sunday of
anarchy since season two
definitely worth going back to if you
haven't fez
the independent video game brought to
you by visionary
phil fish you may have seen this as the
subject of the documentary
indie game the movie fez was
downloadable title for xbox 360 earlier
in the year it is really graphically
simple but conceptually just
unbelievably complex
it involves rotating parts the landscape
around the z-axis that you never really
think about
so it is a 2d game that takes on a 3d
feel there are more easter eggs built
into this thing
than i don't know april on the white
house lawn it is just
there is cryptography and qr codes and
and illusions and
and just it is there is so much to
unpack
that if you played it you know what i'm
talking about if you don't
oh god you have to play this game fez
from phil fish
nice work so that is it for 2012
on the monitor we will be back next week
to start talking about 2013
pop culture releases but until then
we've got a long list of honorable
mentions
that did not we did not have room for in
this list so i want to give shout to
argo ben affleck killing it as usual
aesop rock how to dress well a second
album safety not guaranteed mark duplass
and aubrey plaza in a small little
genre movie speaking of small little
genre movies chronicle great little
superhero sci-fi tale that was presented
with a great deal of polish brian
cavanaugh fiona staples
sci-fi fantasy comic series on image
called saga speaking of image you also
had jonathan hickman's manhattan
chronicles a great alternate history
retelling of the atomic age and the cold
war you also had ed brubaker and sean
phillips coming together to do noir all
over again on image with fatale
you've got the avengers can't forget the
avengers and i think that's it so we'll
see you next week